imagine if you had the most in demand
cyber security skills needed today
imagine if you can learn from some of
today's best minds in academia and
industry alike from your own home on
your own schedule welcome to the simply
learn way of learning we are proud to
bring you our post-graduate program in
cyber security this online bootcamp
combines live and recorded classes
learning modules from mit schwartzman
college of computing and dc council real
world labs and projects 24 7 support
multiple industry certifications and
much more
master the latest cyber security
techniques used to design systems and
protocols that secure applications
networks and devices through a
comprehensive and expertly designed
learning path
join the live classroom session by a
world-class faculty comprising academic
experts and industry practitioners from
anywhere in the world
learn by doing perfect your skill set
with over 25 hands-on projects through
integrated labs and a capstone project
in three domains these projects include
simulations designed to help you learn
fast and tackle the pressing cyber
security challenges of today
network and collaborate with peers from
around the world and attend master
classes from the mit faculty to gain the
well-rounded experience you need to
stand out in today's business world
and at the end of it all you will
receive a postgraduate program
certification from simply learn access
to the mit schwarzman college of
computing experiential learning alumni
community a certified ethical hacker
certificate from ec council and an
executive program completion certificate
from mit
all of this could be yours
just complete our brief program
application and an admissions counselor
will walk you through the prerequisites
welcome
you